my first boyfriend was on runescape I
think I was like 10 or 12 I don't even
remember you know I don't know how old
he was
I thought you know it could have been
anything today we are revisiting some of
our favorite old computer games are they
computer games like internet games true
scape I was a Club Penguin kid Neopets
consumed all of my life made of food and
random places you can do that in
runescape you can do anything I hope
that they haven't updated Neopets for
the new generation I'm hoping that it's
like the Space Jam website it just
stayed where it was I just hope I log on
and I'm like still alive and I have all
my money my name is scarlet Sam one wish
laughs 118 Mya rocks 1 2 3 4 5 Lindsey
rocks 35 corn Diddy Redux password redux
baby 1 2 3 the loading bars the same
nothing's changed everything is still
the same it's this still a functioning
website through there zombies with a
zombies last time Oh cheek oh when I
remember you America Wow all my friends
are here there's a puffle Park a skate
park and a puffle wild I didn't have
that there I am
wait why am I not wearing armor I
thought w-with me bored I was wrong
we love excitement I am excited 500 Neil
points to just spin a wheel I have
Neopets to feed sheep I found it who's
gets a light of computers what a blast
plate for sixes
hell no I got six in my hand you trying
to get that by me cheating there's a
little cave with a pool that you could
do nothing in that would have been a
good improvement to make one room with
something in it what else do you do on
this game other than cook fish it's
getting really dark Oh what got white
again
oh okay maybe some enhancements the Sun
will go out and away just like real life
I forgot how terrible flash is the
patience that I had as a kid for things
to load is amazing like fine for with me
he's not playing five for me I'm not
wasting my time on Brian I forgot what
my name is
I've never battled before let's see if
my child will make me proud it's doing a
lot of damage to me I've died now I feel
sad gone ball I found it so you throw
this ball and then
something happens and it explodes for
how long I waited to find this game it
kind of sucks this game is to be much
more populated in the town than it is
now back then it was like yeah past the
Leprechaun past the cow oh so much
that's me but they want to be friends
yes desperately so planning runescape
again was kind of nostalgic I found the
same joys I found when I was a kid
now that kind of sucked some things were
just as exciting just as fun as I
remembered and so that [ __ ] was boring
there seems to be a lot more theatrics
to it which is really cool they have not
changed anything so I'm assuming nobody
works at Neopets I know that they're
getting rid of the website and just
making it a mobile device probably
because I think more kids go on their
phone now than a computer if you're out
there and you're watching this and you
want to go play Neopets you have my
information and don't change the
password let's make this a community I
want a big-ass house with a lot of
fruits and I want so many neo points I
just clicked on this well and that's my
[ __ ] that's where it all is that's the
girl I know wow oh my god yes